en este vídeo hablaremos sobre cómo usar
la aproximación cuando x es muy pequeña
para resolver problemas de equilibrio
cuando casi es muy grande y con grande
me refiero a que casi es mayor o
aproximadamente igual a 10 a la cuarta
tenemos un vídeo anterior a este en el
que hablamos de cómo usar la
aproximación de x pequeña cuando case
también es pequeña pero en este vídeo
hablaremos de la situación contraria
como dijimos en el vídeo anterior para
resolver este tipo de problemas hay
cuatro pasos el primer paso es suponer
que la reacción ocurre al 100% hacia la
dirección que sea favorecida y en este
caso cuando k es muy grande eso
significa que la reacción se favorece
hacia los productos hacia los productos
el segundo paso es hacer la tabla hice y
después resolver x a partir de esa tabla
hice suponiendo que x es pequeña así que
podemos usar la aproximación cuando x es
pequeña y finalmente el paso más
importante es revisar nuestro resultado
entonces hay que asegurarnos de que el
tamaño de x realmente sea pequeño a
comparación de lo que hayamos dicho que
es más pequeño y también tenemos que
asegurarnos de que obtuvimos una
respuesta correcta al sustituir x para
calcular de nuevo café veamos un ejemplo
el ejemplo es que tenemos una reacción
de n o gaseoso que reacciona con cloro
gaseoso para formar 2 nfl gaseoso y para
esta reacción en particular el valor de
k es igual a 6.25 por 10
cuarta observen que sin duda se
encuentra en el orden de diez a la
cuarta así que podemos usar la
aproximación cuando x es pequeña pero
vamos a hacerlo de dos formas primero
vamos a hacer nuestra tabla y se vamos a
decir que las concentraciones iniciales
son 2.0 molar para n o y 2.0 molar para
cl 2 y no tenemos nada de nfl al
principio ya tenemos nuestra tabla y ce
como siempre y podemos decir ok bueno
vamos a formar una cierta cantidad de
nfl así que ponemos menos 2x para el n
ya que por cada cl 2 que se consume
necesitamos 2 de n y eso significa que
tenemos menos x para cl 2 así se obtiene
una concentración 2x molar del producto
y finalmente cuando se alcanza el
equilibrio tenemos
2.0 molar menos 2x esto lo obtenemos
simplemente sumando la concentración
inicial y la concentración en el cambio
y de la misma forma obtenemos 2.0 molar
menos x para cloro gaseoso y en nuestro
producto al equilibrio
sólo tenemos 2x
pero regresemos a los pasos de los que
hablamos al principio de este vídeo
vamos a ver ya hicimos nuestra tabla
dice que es el paso 2 pero supusimos que
la reacción se lleva a cabo al 100%
hacia la dirección que sea favorecida
pues eso se nos fue nos brincamos el
paso 1 y nos fuimos directamente a la
tabla y se nos pareció algo natural pero
resulta que no es muy bueno ya lo verá
vamos a ver qué pasa si nos brincamos el
paso 1 y continuamos entonces si
continuamos vamos a calcular x
suponiendo que x es pequeña entonces
para nuestra expresión de equilibrio
tenemos que casi es igual a 12 x al
cuadrado entre 2.0 molar menos x que es
la concentración de cl 2 y esto por 2.0
menos 2
y todo eso al cuadrado por la stec yo me
tria que tenemos y es importante
mencionar que empezamos con una reacción
balanceada eso es muy importante porque
si no está balanceada nuestra constante
café será incorrecta entonces antes de
empezar siempre asegúrense de que la
reacción esté balanceada ok entonces ya
escribimos la expresión de café y ahora
vamos a suponer erróneamente pero haré
de cuenta que o no interesa nada sólo
voy a suponer que x es pequeña no me
importa si es una buena suposición o no
entonces si x es pequeña tenemos que
decir que x es mucho más pequeña que 2
molar aquí y aquí así que también
estamos diciendo que 2x es mucho más
pequeño que 2 molar entonces podríamos
decir que esto es aproximadamente igual
a 2x cuadrada
/ 2.0 molar porque como x es mucho más
pequeña que 2 molar la vamos a ignorar
completamente y como x es mucho más
pequeña que 2.0 molar aun si
multiplicamos x por 2 entonces esto será
2.0 molar al cuadrado y si multiplicamos
esto nos queda que es igual a x cuadrada
entre este 2 al cuadrado se cancela con
este así que nos queda que x al cuadrado
entre todos es igual a nuestra constante
case que es igual a 6.25 por 10 a la 4
entonces si multiplicamos ambos lados
por 2 obtenemos que x cuadrada es igual
a 1.25 por 10 a las 5 y por lo tanto x
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de eso
354 y miren aquí es donde ok ya hicimos
el paso 2 y 3 y ahora vamos a revisar
nuestra respuesta pero veamos si nuestra
respuesta es lógica estamos diciendo que
aquí el cambio en la concentración es
354 eso no tiene sentido porque de hecho
nos da una concentración negativa
entonces con ese valor obtenemos
concentraciones negativas para n o hice
l 2 y eso es muy malo así que esto no
nos sirve otra cosa que esto nos dice es
que nuestra suposición fue muy mala para
nuestra ecuación de casi supusimos que x
era mucho más pequeña que 2 pero después
obtuvimos que x es igual a 354
claramente no es más pequeña que 2
entonces al parecer el brincarnos los
pasos fue muy mala idea pero vamos a
intentarlo de nuevo intento número 2
vamos a ver cuál era el paso 1 dice que
hay que suponer que la reacción se lleva
a cabo al 100% en la dirección
favorecida y para este problema en
particular como case es muy grande
decimos que se favorece hacia los
productos eso significa que necesitamos
hacer nuestra tabla hice de nuevo pero
esta vez nuestras concentraciones
iniciales deben estar basadas en la
suposición de que nuestra reacción se
desplaza completamente hacia los
productos y las concentraciones
iniciales las podemos conocer usando la
estéreo metría entonces digamos que al
principio empezamos con una
concentración 2 molar tn
y 2 molar de cl 2 y sabemos que en eeuu
y cl 2 reaccionan en una relación 2 a 1
entonces como tenemos la misma cantidad
de los dos el reactivo limitante sería
el n
eso significa que cuando llegamos al
equilibrio se consume completamente y si
suponemos que se favorecen los productos
entonces nos queda 0 molar de enero y se
produce 2.0 molar del producto y como
tenemos cl 2 en exceso solo usaremos 1
molar de eso para que reaccione con 2
molar
dna por lo tanto nos queda 1 molar este
es el paso especial siguiendo el paso 1
y vamos a suponer suponer
que obtenemos el 100% del producto
bueno la razón por la que hacemos esta
suposición es porque sabemos que acá es
muy grande así que al equilibrio debemos
de obtener todo el producto o la mayor
cantidad de producto ok y ahora vamos
con los siguientes pasos estamos
suponiendo que todo se convierte en
producto pero todavía no llegamos al
equilibrio así que para llegar al
equilibrio vamos a suponer que tendremos
una pequeñísima cantidad de n
entonces tenemos más 2x y esperamos
tener un poco más de cl 2 así que por la
este que oh metría podemos escribir más
x
y esto nos da menos 2x para el n cl
porque esperamos que un poco de esto
reaccione irreversiblemente entonces si
sumamos la concentración inicial y la
concentración en el cambio nos queda 2x
para la concentración de n
para la concentración de cl 2 y 2.0
menos 2x para la concentración de
nuestro producto ok
hasta ahora vamos bien entonces vamos a
sustituir las concentraciones en nuestra
expresión de café como hicimos antes
casi sigue siendo igual a 6.25 por 10 a
la 4 y esto es igual a la concentración
de nfl al cuadrado es decir 2.0 menos 2x
al cuadrado
entre 2 x al cuadrado que corresponde a
la concentración tn o al cuadrado por x
o oops cometí un error esto más bien es
1.0 + x perdón entonces aquí más bien es
x x + 1.0 molar + 1.0 molar ahora si
esta es nuestra expresión de casi
completa sustituyendo las
concentraciones al equilibrio y hasta
ahora no hemos hecho ninguna
aproximación pero vamos a suponer
podemos suponer que x es pequeña
entonces si x es pequeña en realidad eso
significa que x es mucho más pequeña que
1 molar pero también estamos diciendo
que es mucho menor que 2 molar así que
el numerador es aproximadamente igual a
2.0 molar al cuadrado porque decimos que
esto es muy pequeño
mejor pondré que esta es una
aproximación y después en el denominador
el 2x al cuadrado se queda igual
pero como supusimos que x es mucho menor
que 1.0 molar nos queda 1.0 molar ok
entonces ya simplemente multiplicamos
todo esto y nos queda 4 entre 4 x
cuadrada y esto es igual a casi entonces
los 4 se cancelan y nos queda que x
cuadrada es igual a 1 entre case es
decir 6.25 por 10 a la 4 y si aplicamos
la raíz cuadrada en ambos lados de la
ecuación obtenemos que x es igual a
déjeme ver a 4.0 por 10 a la menos 3
molar
y aquí es en donde entra el sentido
común para asegurarnos de que todo
saliera bien esta vez entonces primero
tenemos que preguntarnos a nosotros
mismos o que realmente x es más pequeña
que los números de los que dijimos que
era más pequeña bueno si comparamos x
con 1 podemos ver que es tres órdenes de
magnitud más pequeña eso es bueno y
también si comparamos 2x con 2
nuevamente es tres órdenes de magnitud
más pequeña así que hasta ahora todo
bien pero nuestra prueba final es
sustituir todo de nuevo en la expresión
de café entonces si sustituimos el valor
de x nos queda que casi es igual a 2.0
molar menos 2 por 4.0 por 10 a la menos
3 molar
al cuadrado
entre 2 x 4.0 x 10 a la menos 3 molar
también al cuadrado
esa es la concentración de no2 y
finalmente por la concentración de cl 2
que es 4.0 por 10 a la menos 3 molar más
1.0 molar entonces al multiplicar todo
esto lo que obtenemos es que cace es
igual a 6.23 por 10 a la cuarta y si
comparamos eso con el valor original de
café con el que empezamos podemos ver
que es 6.25 por 10 a la cuarta y eso
está bastante bien porque recuerden que
hicimos una aproximación por eso nuestra
respuesta no es exacta pero se acerca
mucho y si queremos que se acerque aún
más hay otros métodos que podemos usar
pero por ahora para nuestro objetivo
esto nos dice que la aproximación fue
y entonces miren si acá se es muy grande
lo que necesitamos es suponer que
obtenemos el 100% de los productos al
llenar nuestra tabla hice eso nos
ayudará a suponer con más seguridad que
x es pequeña